okay
what we just came out of
was all kinds of hectic
um
the the bad
soldier
is dead
i
think
somebody may have been scratched i don't
know
i feel like i made a lot of choices in
the heat of the moment and i'm concerned
i'm glad this guy's alive though i do
like him um we're still just trying to
get out
of this actual hellhole you're trying to
cross me
don't leave me
come on
you're dead i don't think he ever would
have he seems like a nice dude you think
i'm afraid of a jarhead
yes celine yeah you tell him boy
that looks like i still don't know how
to get out though
one of us holds it
are you sure about that
all right
[Music]
i don't know if somebody like could have
lost a finger there or something that
would have been spicy
oh my oh are you okay
what do you think
it's blocked
i gotta find another way around well
that actually didn't answer the question
that's actually kind of unrelated to if
you're okay or
not rude but fair
i think there's a way through
i just need to clear it from my side
do it quick
those things could be anywhere
he's right
you got any idea what we're dealing with
they are vampires they're vampires
not possible
my phone i don't know that i buy
vampires exactly but if something looks
like it smells like [ __ ] you don't have
to taste it to know that it's [ __ ]
believe me they're vampires
we must work together to defeat them
yeah it's beginning to look like that
beginning jason after what we've been
through come on now
beginning
wait what just happened to this open by
itself no
i completely thought they were in
different places that's my backhand
it opened because he offered it it makes
more sense it was like aren't they in
totally different areas now because i
was expecting selena have to go walk by
himself it's fine it's fine it's fine
everything's fine what's the first thing
you're gonna do when we get out of here
hold my son
yeah i wish him happy birthday what
about you
what will you do
i'll listen to you probably just go for
a drink i make myself smaller
um i was wondering in one of the
previous episodes
where i put the charges both in the
middle and to the left
if you run through the middle does it
just like kill everybody all at once
it probably does or did they go wait no
we shouldn't do that
i don't know i'm curious
oh no this isn't a premonition this is
just a slab
that's somebody being killed with a
butter
knife very difficult r32 great car shout
out to nissan
love a gtr
um
alrighty
no i wanted to read that
no
pick it back up you got your head
screwed on
you gotta ask
what the hell made you sign up with
saddam
good question
unintelligible is dead that looks like
it says mikey money
mindy mindy
i sat with her in her final moments
telling her how sorry i was
unintelligible hell for second place for
placing my vanity above our love
when unintelligible the end of
everything i knew she unintelligible
unintelligible she made me swear to bury
this place
poor mindy oh there's also mary when
mary spoke about the end of everything i
knew she
sinned
he guess unintelligible definitely
unintelligible
i'm curious about his answer to this
question but he did he say nothing is
that maybe because i was already
interrupting something
not that deep that pit not that deep all
right let's keep going
it's to honor the dead it's the reason i
fight
no it's as good a reason as any i don't
know it's a damn good reason
the only reason
i have no grievance with you
i think salim seems like a respectful
man i have no grievance with you
maybe you need to switch on the nude
listen
there was a man once who built his house
on the banks of a river
when the floods came his wall washed
away when the droughts came
the water dried up and the man was
thirsty
the insects bit this man's flesh yet
each night
he says to his wife we have all the fish
we can eat
your people chose this war jason
wow let me get home
oh
uh oh
oh no no no no no no no
don't forget about it
oh i should have let go oh
no it's okay you got it i was thinking i
couldn't
i hope that works but i really hope that
little baby knife works on a vampire
on the steak though
right
push
[Music]
cool
cool
[Music]
i sure would get the [ __ ] out of here
yes
let's do
that
i've been trying
but honestly like that is the thing
about this game is i have no idea what
the solution is
i guess it's linea in a way that like
how the [ __ ] should i know how we get
out of here dude
i'm incapable of solving these problems
i do not know the answers
whatsoever
i was wrong
other than sunlight
looks to me like a medical bee
this could come in handy
if you want to stick 60-year old
explosive in your back be my guest
all right
those chemical weapons are close right
i'm just going for it
the camp is an uproar workers i'm
missing a lady bradshaw but i can guess
she yearns for the same fate that she
wants to be she wants to be
unintelligible
don't we all
all i want in life to just not be
perceived if everybody could stop
even considering my existence
intelligible we'd all be better off
jason i'm gonna need you
to move
um thanks bud thanks that was uh
that was a bit of a problem
okay
i love the cup mini game that's my
favorite thing in this game so far is
the move the cup across mini game
patient history mary age six
9 30
19 30. i don't know why i read that
wrong temp impulse dangerously high
subject mostly unconscious occasionally
wakes and screams sweating sickness
continues saline supply love detected
movement under the skin of the abdomen
around the location of the adrenal
glands
r suggests exploratory surgery but i
fear and might not survive the operation
2010
what
oh my god
these experiments weren't for that long
no their times
their times it's 1930 and 2010 not years
i was like
wow that's a
that's a thing that just happened in
this plot um
subject weakening more we've been under
skin scene parasitic organism time of
death 2013 so they don't live for even
an hour
it's real quick they they don't they
don't last very long they're gonna die
pretty fast all right all right all
right i think if i practiced his accent
i could probably do it eventually
i could do a mcconaugh if i just listen
to some videos of him talking because uh
the accent's wrong
it needs work it needs work or typical
specimen contains an inordinate amount
of blood in its stomach analysis a blood
sample shows high density of adrenaline
does the organism feed on fear
okay instills fear on its victim gets
adrenaline pumping attacks
interesting
okay
i just need to be more ballsy
it's kind of impossible to just not be
afraid if someone's like don't be scared
when has that literally ever worked
whatever's down there those explorers
got there first
hold up will ya
what are you doing
you think they're still alive
that's hopeful
i hope it's good
i'm pretty sure everybody's still alive
i know um my favorite boy got injured a
little bit
and i killed that first girl
shot her right in the face
she was about to turn you know
oh
all right getting a broke bun oh yeah
okay
it's interesting
that your wife
it's funny how you can know someone for
years and never really know them
never knew her doll was married what
i have no idea my captain was married oh
it's just kevin the show you were with
earlier
interesting
you didn't make it it works for me only
bad guy to deal with
that time will come when you'll deeply
regret this matter
i don't carry regrets
i don't know about that
i'm unconvinced
it was a strange cut
okay is the radioactive in here
oh it's that spooky
oh it's green very spooky
spooky spooky
well this place is a jack-in-the-box
like the food chain
i don't know if they've ever had
jack-in-the-box you know
i've only just this year started having
taco bell what do you make of it
because we didn't have it in australia
when i was there it is there now
sorry i'm trying to talk about jack jack
in the box you guys um the supreme
contract at taco bell
i don't think delicious
bean burrito
the winch still looks functional
no
no we are not going down there
the archaeologist didn't make it out
what does that tell you we're not
archaeologists our world is up there not
down below well there's an army of
monsters between us and the world above
what why would you go down fired up
you're crazy
if those vampires come from anywheres
down there you really want to find them
in their own home what i've been doing
since i set foot in this country
get that elevator working
i'm in massive disagreement jason
i really think we should do anything we
can to go up
enormous disagreement don't feel like
using the old generators is a good idea
one of them is bound to explode at any
[ __ ] second
nope no
wouldn't catch me doing this i'd prefer
to visit jack in the box
[ __ ] that
also yeah you made a ton of noise this
was dumb this was you
wow
[Applause]
listen i'm sure narratively speaking
they'll be fine because i didn't have a
choice
but um
i don't feel great about it
i feel like mistakes
horror has awoken from its slumber and
is hungry for blood
shall we see how many have fallen into
shadow
two are dead right three
rachel found her way back to the light
well done all alive
although don't get complacent
their lives still hang by a thread
let's hope nothing
unfortunate has befallen sergeant k
those taken by the abyss
seldom lived to tell the tale
as for jason
good to
obviously it looks like a video game
that does not look completely photo
risky but it just it's just
compelling to look at you i don't want
to seem like an ungracious host but time
is against us
sure is i'll be here to greet your
charges as they cross the finishing line
or to bury what remains of them under it
[Music]
ooh i saw the skull there was a skull
there oh spooky
oh my god it's been so long since i've
seen the sky in this game
ah is this what piece is a dino
oh
a little hope
i didn't expect that
interesting choice
wow okay what the [ __ ] happened with
that animation smells
what the [ __ ]
we're in hillbilly territory what we
expect are you okay cantaloupe caviar
oh my god
was she a vampire the whole time
i recall a certain somebody saying that
she wanted to go ice climbing ice
climbing is
relaxing
i can't think of anything less relaxing
sounding than ice climbing
what is it
the guy who served me
i don't know he was
just looking at me pretty strange
yeah he probably doesn't get to see a
woman like you around these parts very
often
especially one who showered
nice
that's them when they were still married
saying some weird [ __ ]
such as
it's nothing we should go
no come on tell me where i would talk to
someone i'm in a relationship with is so
different
he said i'll never again be as happy as
i am now
no what does that mean
you don't believe him do you
of course not
i don't think people have these
conversations but if somebody in a dyna
objective
rage is to make you happy
it doesn't matter where we are or what
we're going through i'll always put a
smile on your face
see
i told you
[Music]
next time all you have to do is whistle
and i'll come running to defend your
honor
oh like my very
loyal puppy dog
all right
i'm more than capable of looking after
myself
nice now get your toe off my dash you
hillbilly
oh the car accident
i forgot about that
still though okay
if someone was creepy to me
and i go back to my partner the first
thing i would have done when i got in
that car was be like bro you will not
believe what just [ __ ] happened
i'm not gonna be like
the man in there said some pretty
strange stuff but we don't have to talk
about it just i'd be like
brother this this holy [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] ridiculous man
i do call partners bro probably more
often than i should come to think of it
so yes i think she maybe got bitten what
the [ __ ]
or attacked i'm not really sure
hmm
didn't he get attacked
you might be
nick i thought i lost you i thought i'd
lost you oh you guys
[Music]
oh is that eric
right
eric
of this guy he definitely
ah [ __ ] it's malfunctioning
colonel you gotta go shame
you too nick you're coming with us come
on
oh god okay immediately into a chase
sequence
[ __ ]
he's a little bit funny
[Music]
over there
did nobody else see the door what
oh so is this the room that the other
guys were just saying
[Applause]
bro he that your man's a marathon
sprinter out here i don't like i don't
like anything
dude not you you're the only one i
really actually like okay well maybe
it's not gonna be so bad she's gonna
kick you a bit like a real human
[Music]
dude if you don't help him
he wouldn't though woody
[ __ ] i want him to help
[ __ ] i'm sorry eric i'm i'm doing this
out of character because i don't like
you
i just
sacrificed you
[Music]
probably wouldn't have helped him though
and i tried to like role play them
i was selfish i didn't want jason to go
thank me later let's move out maybe he
would though as maybe the
maybe the
sempefy commander thing would override
i'm just gonna let myself think that
that's how i'm gonna justify what i just
did
that he would
for his duty
this [ __ ] [ __ ] just stay no stay
dead just stay dead
so dramatic
yeah she's in trouble huh
you think that thing's gone
looked like it went down that tunnel
he's alive jason's alive
it's a good idea maybe things aren't
going so badly after all
back there oh
thanks for looking out for me
one good turn deserves another
all right let's find cole check
what are you waiting for a written
invitation let's go
it's time
it's absolutely not the time we can't
keep playing this man
nick listen no no no you listen
all right [ __ ] you kill don't know i
called him jason i'm like a real man not
some chump
you kind of lose me here i don't know
that this is the time rachel you
you said you tell him when the time was
right all of this relationship drama is
just tell him the truth
a bit inappropriate
you know where this your marriage ended
a year ago seems like a hate charge
he's right
it is time
roll it out for us now
right [ __ ] now yes now we may not
have another chance
fine
eric
you and i
okay we have something very special you
guys decided you're a safe hangout
nothing
this isn't about choosing
it's about knowing what's best for me
i don't have feelings for you eric
not anymore
you either nick
we're done what
what the [ __ ] i don't believe him
believe it you just kissed him we were
over a year ago
i don't need anyone's help to climb out
of this house
well
we both know
maybe we can stop [ __ ] around and go
find cold check
what the [ __ ]
i am bewildered it just happened
why did she kiss him then
this [ __ ] crazy this [ __ ] crazy none
of this would have happened if you
stayed at home well i didn't want him
that's funny i was thinking the same
thing about you
god damn
that really called me off god
[ __ ] just
women you know so indecisive
and moody
you can't even keep up
i feel much more comfortable with this
jack-in-the-box elevator which i now
presume all jack in the box
have
if not i would consider it to be false
advertisement
i've seen some [ __ ] up [ __ ] in my life
this is actually really pretty
certainly looks like a hive do you like
to wait for them or
i need to be a smart ass my new favorite
[ __ ] nick
okay explore the dangerous stare a lot
for danger
consider it done my friend consider it
done you got any any cups for me to move
because i will unless you watch me move
from cups
finds legend 3
cool
oh
many finds in the temple confirm our
hypothesis that the temple was used for
sacrifice we know that a century-long
drought afflicted the arcadian empire
the same dry spell that affected the old
kingdom in egypt the drought caused the
abandonment of many cities across
mesopotamia and drew the gewd and
barbarian tribes down from the mountain
to the plains bringing them into
conflict with the arcadians
in this temple we see evidence of an
increasingly desperate attempt to turn
the tide by appeals to the gods related
fights black onyx onyx stones are
symbolic of negative energy and of
calamity perhaps due to the belief that
evil
demons inhabited the earth
and a whole stone the stone shows
figures praying towards an eclipse
combined with ah six the peace portrays
an eclipse that pre-stages a disaster
i
wonder if the eclipse ending means that
we'll survive like do we just have to
survive
the eclipse
and technically how long is an eclipse
because you can't always see them all
over the world which i presume to mean
they aren't 24 hour right
logically they must be shorter
okay
oh what is that
oh they gave me goosebumps
looks
they don't teach you american science at
school
american sites
is that a thing
belongs to
randolph hodgson
maybe he's got some intel that could
help
i can't help him
it's true
all the pages are gone
cool
how could he not see that from the
outside
oh you couldn't be like peter's gone
don't look inside it to check
okay
oh i see
oh this is all the pages that have been
scattered everywhere
when this temple falls my wife and i
will be unintelligible i owe her that at
least the portrait that i carry in my
watch case is the mary that i remember
not that unintelligible
is the temple set to fall
this is
architected
those aren't naturally occurring ox
[Music]
it's like some
alien [ __ ]
some real xenomorph [ __ ] out here
[Music]
it's cool
[Music]
yeah what you said
i wasn't expecting that
because of like
prometheus
my brain
goes is it a ship
mayhaps it is a
ship
they're aliens
not vampires vampire aliens potentially
what is this hell
is this even real
i don't know man i don't know
we are being judged
god
is punishing us all for the mistakes
we've ever made
zayn is all i have left in this world
unless his son after my wife left us
i gave him my old
i wanted him to have everything i didn't
single parent
the [ __ ] gig
poppin's still there i thought that
they'd fix that on like a day one patch
but my boy husband
is still here
he's going to london
to university
if only you stop stealing
it's pronounced university
this morning
i found the good zayn had stolen
i left a message with my neighbor to
tell zane how
angry i was with him
is that the last thing he would do
it would suck if that was your last
i miss message so much
you could have said hey
i'm super mad also i love you though
didn't do that did you
because your conscience cleared jason
controller vibrated almost fell off me
um
let's just go for boating
this place
i'm i was waiting for somebody to
[ __ ] say something along those lines
somebody's gotta cut to the chase
i can hear you thinking
we're waiting for something to happen
maybe we should take the initiative and
make something happen
hey
whatever happens kind of just try and
make them work together
we'll stand together
the only way
i just want you losers to survive all
right it's just it's stressful out here
i i feel like you have no plan
and you're both dumb
i don't know why we came down here
instead of going up
but we did
trying to make it work
302 hours huh
so what they need like four more hours
probably i don't know where they are
time of year it is a lot of questions
what are the logistics
what time zone are you in
oh pretty
they really gave up on the textures of
the
i don't know what they are
the pistol things they just really gave
up
uh-oh
i should put my hand on the controller
stressing myself out at this point
stay close
this is very cool though like i'm
interested in whatever the [ __ ] this is
find a way to strike back
all right gotta be where those things
come from
i think so
question is
where the hell are they
good question my friend
they seem to be like sleeping down here
oh is that bats
yep
that would have sucked
it just died right there
sleep
over here
what do you make of it
this place could have been down here for
thousands of years
god didn't make these creatures been
designed
it's possible we've got this wrong way
around
what's that supposed to mean
check this out
sounds like music
i don't sound like any music from where
i'm from
okay maybe not music
but the uh
cool
you've seen those [ __ ] they're
not exactly the chatty type this has a
lot more depth than i feel like i
expected it to like underestimate them
look at this place you didn't have to do
all this you could have just had scary
vampires
it's late
it's everywhere
is it just me or
is it alive
it's a motorbike
it was riding a cool bike
groot
what happened to you on your cool bike
sleep
check this out
it's one of those creatures
only older
ancient
you don't think it's alive do you
touch it
you touch it
nobody touch it nobody has to touch it
don't touch it don't touch it
oh my god
not doing it i'm not doing it
nope
hmm
oh is that a person
that's a does a human
oh but the the skull guy was wearing
that kind of gob oh that he's a human
wow
the most preserved off his face that's
cool
holy [ __ ]
look at him
check out that armor
this guy's goddamn biblical
yeah
wow
that's cool
[ __ ]
did you see that
is still alive
that's impossible
in this place
everything's possible
fucker's been alive all this time
sitting here will have a head
fluid
it must have preserved his flesh
his brain
what should we do
what the [ __ ] well [ __ ] she had enough
time to get used to it
i'm serious
um
i know you would attract the vampires oh
that's a good point
i was gonna i was gonna shoot him i've
been in america for too long
damn
maybe it has healing properties then
this looks like a butthole
look at it look at that little butthole
okay
it's very prometheus
but i'm definitely interested
did not see anything going in this
direction at all
i would never have guessed
i thought that the curse was enough
though i guess
these games generally do always have
something like
end up
being explainable if that makes sense
usually the
story is explainable in some facet
like scientifically explainable
not that
ancient aliens
are
that much more believable than just
regular vampires
i read this book once when i was like
14 or so
which i've tried to find but never could
um
that ran on the core assumption that
every single myth ever was real
it was just every mythological creature
lived in at one place which i'm sure a
lot of other mediums have done
but that they were all evil
just occasionally accidentally got
inside like the wolf among us
before that came out okay can you see
the bone is ruptured where they should
be as those many stole his face inside
out
what are you saying
maybe these things weren't originally
vampires
maybe they got infected
oh
that's interesting
so they were just
aliens that became vampires
because of where they landed and maybe
that's the case
um
it's getting spicy
spooky
clicking
sleep
what is it
i think we hit the mother lode
whoa that's lightning
what this is totally a ship
oh my god
yeah
and i am thinking what you're thinking
why were you both thinking cocoons oh
because they look like cocoons yeah they
totally are i don't know that that will
help us here though why is that helpful
what's the plan
that's gonna explode again quietly
okay
i just really feel like we should have
planned
is that just me though
i just
i don't know about all this you guys i
do not know about all this
okay oh [ __ ] uh
this would be a great time to have a
jumpscare i'm so focused on looking at
the ground they would destroy me
that's not gonna work
okay
i feel like that sap thing has to be
relevant they're not going to just have
that and not pay it off right
i don't know why but
maybe the intent is to explain that
that's how they all living that long
enough tunes
hello
[Applause]
hey [ __ ] this
i got something for you
they're all just gonna wake up i what is
the plan
everybody we don't have plans
and i don't feel good about it
what is the plan i'll come here oh god
whoa
humans found here too
[ __ ] dicky you turned up like the
[ __ ] cavalry
i thought you were dead
not my time
girl
yeah crawling through that tunnel was a
highly unpleasant experience
she's not
i don't trust that she's okay i think
there's something wrong with that take
my hand
i wonder if we can heal her like maybe
there'll be like
something down here
i'm glad you're here man
this place
i could be reading it she could just be
like tired or some [ __ ] but i feel like
she's dying i don't know
it all just got very mass effect very
fraternal what is this place
we need a plan
i have those things strong get the [ __ ]
out good there's too many of them my
friend thank you jordan k god bless you
guys he's my favorite so we got um eight
clips of 556 fmj three 40 mil high x
rounds a couple of nine mil pistols four
clips between them we'll make that work
and one block of composition c4
okay
what about the uv lamp
took a knock but i can fix it
just need a minute
all in is not enough
batteries though oh you got this
uh it's all unpredictable we work with
what we got
our fuses are shot but we can use the c4
to detonate them let's just hope they
still pack a punch the vampires come
from those cocoons you saw how many
there were in that vault
there could be thousands in there
should we blow them up
burn as many of those [ __ ] as
we can and head for the surface what do
you think sergeant
i'm not gonna allow him to carry a
pistol we are way past that point now
man
we stand together as one
still got that med kit that'd be a good
time to use it
it's looking pretty late i can only
patch up one person [ __ ]
press back home would have a field day
with this
oh he patched him up oh oh i thought
he'd make me choose our explorer friends
were here too
we should search this place before gonna
be okay
there also got it
what about rachel
i guess you can't
med kit an infection
okay
what is this
ah
who the [ __ ]
what
i have no idea what to make of that
okay music
huh
as i discover more about the musical
language language of these creatures my
mind spins and wondered how they came to
be here did they soar through the skies
in the days of dinosaurs did their great
empire span the globe while we were
still swinging from the trees they are
dead now their forms are somewhat like
our own but everything else about them
is alien
to life as we know it the console
displays what appears to be a
constellation of stars cetus as seen
from earth did they come here from
beyond crossing great gulps of space to
land here were they trying to get home
they are for sure aliens vamp aliens
how confident are you that they'll work
they'll work this thing with you
me and uh
it's very confusing i'm not upset with
you i'm just saying it's very confusing
keep your head clear of everything but
the task ahead you kissed him and then
broke up with they will live
what the [ __ ]
does that mean nick is available
because oh something i'm saying
i'm into it
here let me help you
it's fine
i've done it before i've done it many
times since
shut the [ __ ] up eric
um
you just go defensive tell me won't it
[ __ ]
what am i saying what is wrong with me
oh rachel are you okay deal me won't it
oh she's getting infected i'm fine
i'm fine she got the clap that's what
happens when you're a [ __ ] rachel
chlamydia
less spoken about side effect
foul pullman new equipment requests
pickaxes rope plywood
arc lamps crowbars gas masks
two whoever finds it for him
is it really all about these tablets
[ __ ] i haven't read it yet can you slow
down a second
i've sabotaged the dynamite to prevent
my colleagues from stealing this temple
to the world that's [ __ ] up lady
broadshot was right to bring me here
these creatures are a key to limitless
power there are secrets here that would
allow humanity to reach across the stars
perhaps even achieve immortality itself
please safeguard this ruin and do not
think badly of me for what i have done i
serve only the future
hmm
i don't think that you get to like make
really big ethical
um errors subjective of course
um that could potentially damn mankind
and say don't judge me bro
you a hater no judgment hey
i live my own life no regrets i think
you kind of deserve the judgment and you
can't ask people not to in daylight and
a cold one yeah it comes with the boys
somewhere that whole mess with you nick
it's on the open right
i don't know why everybody here thinks
it's this is
everything else
why just keep you sick
they are coming we must end it here with
that intelligible if there is a time my
last act will be to dictate this diary
onto unintelligible found in the rubble
it can serve as a warning to any who
unintelligible
the bones of this temple are drenched in
blood we have set foot on an uncharted
shore
and roused something ancient and wicked
a blasphemy that comes in indescribable
shapes and forms
for eons we lived as children in this
world
unaware of the horrors that slumber
beneath our future
now we have blindly thrown open the
gates to madness
i fear being taken
but i must do what i must
we must steal this place for eternity
for all mankind
mary
i'm sorry
i think my mouth
is right
maybe it could have been sealed though
the tremors would have probably happened
eventually
i don't know that ceiling enough even
would have fixed anything
[Music]
none of you will either love
not after the clap gotcha
punch victim implants parasite parasite
gestates host death parasite takes over
so we're at the parasite gestates phase
rachel
i
think uh have i looked at everything i
have right
have we spoken to everyone
ah
okay
[Music]
oh
it's singing
okay
there's meaning here
it's a language formed from chords
scales sonics it's quite pretty
mary was a pianist
she deciphered it
she thought these carvings represented
the stars
do you see
it's cetus the whale
we're a long way from the night sky
that's a mystery
according to the journal there was only
one scale of sound in the device
but mary was studying it alone
i think there may be another
i'm going to need your help what can i
do this console is too big to operate
single-handedly
okay
[Music]
erotic
i don't know what you want me to do here
all right
[Music]
miss following his hand
[Music]
i have no [ __ ] clue what i'm doing
right now
seems to be working i don't know
[Music]
you guys are much calmer about
everything that's happening right now
than i am that's all i want to say
i don't feel good about this at all
and mary believed that these creatures
were once peaceful
your language was one of music
how could they not feel emotion
when the tragedy fell upon them
their great empire
collapsed
their music fell silent and they turned
on each other
what happened
sickness and madness i wonder if she
always had to turn or if i made a an
error somewhere that
whatever caused her infection
now they're creatures of hate
animals
dead things
with no one left to kill
so they
rachel
rachel
it happened slower than this to the
other check
maybe we just slowed down a little bit
slowed down rachel
rachel look at me
she has it
it's inside her
ah that's unpleasant
well that's pretty cool i take it back
this seems like it's for the best this
is sick
confirmed
came to earth ages ago
alliance
they came from the stars
this isn't their home
it's an arc
do something just turning into one of
them
i don't know what we do here man
please rachel you have to hold on
it's killing me
the other chick was so much tougher than
you though pull her the [ __ ] down
we can still save her there's got to be
a way we can't lose her there's no i
agree there's got to be a way hold her
down jason i don't agree like you killed
clarice
i'm gonna say don't do it
jason
not yet do it
we're in the hub now i have to put you
down
i feel like
we can find a solution here jason
they're not gonna have two of them die
this way please
put down the gun
you were going to shoot me
the hell were you thinking that's the
only thing i was thinking
wait wait i suggest something [ __ ] man
just say it there may be another way the
fluid in the cocoons
oh [ __ ] i think i know where you're
going with this what's she talking about
it keeps the flesh alive but it stops
the aging
how could you possibly know that
a man covered in this fluid he should
have been dead but he was alive it kept
him alive we just gave her another
right there couldn't stop this
are you for real
that's crazy we don't know anything
about it
it could stop her from transforming the
cocoon will keep her safe until we
return with help it's our only hope
yes
just do it
just do it
anything to stop this
i'm not super confident in the plan but
i'm like more confident
it then
just killing her i feel like there's a
way to help
but i don't think they'd have two people
turned to this and like she doesn't look
as dead that was the thing that got me
about the other girl was she just looked
so dead
rachel
just a bit unwell
not already then maybe we could burn the
infection out of her i'll do it she's
dying
oh that'd be nice
oh
that's
oh that's terrible inside me
i'm gonna kill that [ __ ] thing
i'm uncomfortable oh that's gross as
[ __ ]
oh my god
um
okay i'm going to leave it there because
this is just over an hour which is
perfect i think we probably only have
one more session in this is my guess
it's gonna be the resolution i'm gonna
show anything
um hopefully i'll get to it with less
time in between than i have for this
episode has been super busy so
yeah but um
wow
that's [ __ ] gross